hi my name is Sheila so you notice a  burrito here at captioned rate I  reminded my profession and team member  to make this attribution that friendly  show our death wish you can enjoy  themselves shall the internet which it  is like a spider web of computer  connection Millie millions of people use  it every day you can do many different  things on internet for example emailing  webcamming with your friends or shopping  with a new dress or making pictures  jokes neiman also from the comfort of  your own computer screen the internet is  like a postal delivery system I yield a  laconic Wi-Fi capable to share  information all my the world obviously  that's how meme is spread all over the  internet because information shared very  easily our lives and communications  change tragically